dans le royaume des morts vivants et
autres créatures effrayantes
il ya aussi de la place pour l'amusement
pour s'en rendre compte il fallait
participer au tournoi de volley ball
organisé dimanche dernier par le club de
bois d'arcy loup garou revenant et
autres personnages aimable se sont
affrontés de part et d'autre du filet on
a beaucoup de costumes un petit peu
improvisée en général de manière
plus récurrente on a assez dracula vous
en avait un sur ma droite qui est en
train de jouer et après des fantômes et
des squelettes difficile de dire qui du
fantôme ou du squelette ce match au
mieux de toute façon aujourd'hui la
victoire du match ne semble pas être la
récompense la plus recherchée pour le
meilleur costume en fait on a fait une
petite statuette pour répondre et
récompenser le meilleur costume et en
plus le vainqueur aura un ballon volé
cette année et se déguiser pour jouer au
volley n'est pas la chose la plus aisée
il faut savoir user pour garder toute sa
mobilité des quatre jeunes ont joué avec
question
ça va les bonnes ne tiennent pas très
bien la perruque je n'ai déjà enlevé
pour le reste il y avait un péché
chaque année on essaie de trouver un
autre déguisement dernier j'étais en
zombies cette année chez un vampire
c'est avec ma copine on essaye de
trouver un costume pour nous deux pour
être assorti c'est bon enfant et puis
comme c'est du loisir forcément je vous
jure on joue le jeu quoi petite pause
déjeuner bien méritée pour nos villes un
héros il faut tenir 21 points pendant un
match
au final du suspense et du rire de quoi
nous donner envie de venir défier ces
créatures maléfiques l'an prochain